hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got five of this week's very best
stories and gaming all ready to go for
you now unfortunately we do film this
show in Australia on an American
Thursday which means I don't have any
new info on Star Wars Battlefront please
tweet me all the exciting things when I
can tell you about star wars battlefront
though is that if you have an xbox one
and EA access you'll be able to play it
first microsoft's aaron greenberg has
confirmed that battle front will arrive
on EA access first the service that runs
you five bucks a month and provides
early albeit usually limited access to
upcoming EA titles playstation rejected
EA access in favor of promoting their
own subscription service so the program
is only available on xbox one star wars
battlefront is due out at the end of
this year unless they announced
something different in their live stream
in which case you can let me know in the
comments
bungie lost a significant destiny update
this week and for those of you still
playing here's the answer destiny's
update 1.12 is available to tide you
guys over until the games next expansion
how's the Wolves lands in May the latest
patch includes a lot of community
requested updates including more vault
space and an item lock functionality to
help you avoid accidentally deleting
that sweet gun you finally earn on top
of that there's also been some changes
to special and heavy ammo drops as a
cheap stuff we're spending your money on
this week humble bundle is featuring a
bunch of EA games that you can pay
whatever you want for you can get dragon
age origins peggle dead space 2 medal of
honor allied assault war chest and
command and conquer generals for
whatever damn price you please then if
you pay more than the current average of
four bucks and 91 sense you can also
pick up plants vs zombies garden warfare
the jewels three massive x2 and dragon
age 2 you might already have a bunch of
those but either way that's a whole lot
of walking games for your money
project cars release info about its
various frame rates and resolutions this
week and as always people have had an
awful lot to say about it project cause
is touching a maximum of 12 k resolution
for PC that's with the game running on
three monitors if you're confused as to
how we made the jump from for K to 12 k
so fast first console versions will run
at 60 frames and on ps4 you'll get a
resolution of 1080p while on Xbox one
it'll run at 900p the developer have
said they'll reveal details for the wii
u version at a later date you can find
the full pc minimum and recommended
specs on gamespot finally at the start
of this wave we've got a few more
details on call of duty black ops 3
Activision have called this upcoming
entry the quote deepest and most
ambitious call of duty game ever which
is basically what they say every year
the source code of the call of duty
website has revealed a whole lot more
however black ops 3 will apparently be
set in a twisted dark future where a new
breed of Black Ops soldier has emerged
and the lines of becoming blurred
between humanity and technology
technology in the form of military
robotics there's also going to be a
campaign multiplayer and zombie mode as
we've pretty much come to expect let me
know down in the comments and star wars
battlefront has got you excited and why
seriously because I don't know anything
new about it at this point this week on
site check out my gist episode on mods
we want to see in GTA 5 the UK team
transform big hero into an angel in
Skyrim mods and in two minutes get you
ready for the witcher 3 that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
this week as always have yourself a
great weekend and I'll catch you again
on Monday
you